we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's a call about
tipping a subject about which I feel
very strongly
do you like to give tips at restaurants
no but I do it
I think that people should stop tipping
at restaurants
you might say well that's bad for the
you know Bakers well
if you keep tipping at a restaurant
the restaurant owner
will continue to not pay a living wage
to the waitress or bartender
if everyone stops tipping
then obviously the waitress and
bartender will leave and not work at the
restaurant
and now the restaurant is stuck
with food that they can serve to their
customers
and when that happens
they will either
close shop
or reevaluate their
payroll
and they will also reevaluate their
prices so listen I wanna I've been up
front I hate tipping culture and how it
has developed I don't like the
inconsistency of it I don't like the
increased nature of more and more places
where you're you're allowed to tip a lot
of this is driven by companies like
square and stripe who put those payment
tablets they collect a portion of every
dollar so it's to the advantage of the
companies that do the payment tablets to
offer tipping for everything and then a
we'll just collect more money
um I tip well everywhere I go I tip
housekeeping when I stay in a hotel and
I you know uh the valet people i t i I
tip everywhere but I am very very much
against the entire thing the problem
with saying if we just stop tipping the
restaurants will have to adjust first of
all the Tipping has gone Way Beyond
restaurant at this point and the first
thing that's going going to happen is if
restaurants immediately play that out
um and by the way some states some state
law
allow the my understanding is that if
the tips don't get that tipped wage up
to the minimum wage the restaurant owner
already has to make up that difference
that's my belief but we should we should
fact check that in in the immediate if
restaurants all of a sudden because
everybody stop tipping needed to pay
employees dramatically more they would
immediately increase prices uh
significantly at the restaurant now this
is effectively what has happened the
tips subsidize and this is what has
happened at restaurants that now say we
include a service charge please don't
tip and the prices already reflect that
the 12 sandwich might just cost you 15
but they will say please don't tip we've
we have a service charger many
restaurants in New York City have
already done this you look at the menu
and it says we are we pay our employees
well the price is already reflect that
or we have added a four percent
surcharge for the back of the house and
tip is already inclusive on the prices
or whatever the case may be honestly I'm
I'm more or less for that sort of thing
and I know that at least in the
immediate we're just going to pay more
in order to not tip but there are a
bunch of different issues with the The
Tipping model and it includes that when
people come from different countries you
don't always know what's expected I was
recently in the UK
the UK has now taken to they
automatically include 12 and a half
percent so you don't have to think about
it you can ask for it to be removed but
the bill comes out and it automatically
says 12 and a half percent tip and what
I like about that is I don't have to
think about it it just is what it is but
my preference would be eliminate tipping
put real pricing that reflects the total
cost of paying employees well on the
menu and then I can look at the menu and
determine whether I think that this is a
restaurant that I want to visit but I
think that if we all just stop tipping
cold turkey it'll be terrible for
workers I don't believe it'll have the
effect that our caller believes it will
have remember Monday Memorial Day this
coming Monday our one day membership
special if you're thinking about signing
up I would encourage you to do so at a
humiliatingly huge discount that we will
be offering on Monday you can be
notified via email by getting on our
newsletter at davidpackman.com bonus
show today will be great we'll talk
about the 1.3 billion dollar fine that
meta has been hit with we will talk
about the move to expel Adam Schiff from
Congress and we will talk about the
latest with this city bike lawsuit that
is going on it's crazy all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money there everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad I can't
possibly say it any better than that so
we will end the show and see you on the
bonus show or back here tomorrow